hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen mod review heute von dem
motto mitmachen zweck dann seht ihr
schon toll da race minimap singen kann
ich nicht das lasse ich jetzt mal wieder
sondern erkläre euch was dieser mod mit
sich bringt und zwar wie der name schon
sagt einige maps oft das was ich auf
euch ja dass man etwas also wir haben ja
dieser mini med nämlich ziemlich viele
einstellungen erstmalig gehe kurz in er
damit jetzt ist sie ausgeblendet musik
gar nicht
ihr seht oben rechts nun dieser mini map
da seht ihr diesen roten pfeil und
darauf ich mich immer laufe ich immer
hin und her ob ich mich immer hinterher
genau da kann ich jetzt hin und her
laufen also ich werde halt immer als
roter ford um angezeigt die welt bewegt
sich nicht allerdings der fall also die
map da ist immer norden also da ist
jetzt süden gerade da ist norden da ist
dings hier westen und da ist osten also
dings ist bei mir westen das müsst ihr
immer verstehen
naja jedenfalls habe mir bei dieser map
ziemlich viele einstellungen wir schon
sehen ich habe mich ein kleines haus
gebaut ein bisschen halloween stil sich
mit kürbis also ich weiß ich kann nicht
bauen und dass sie total scheiße aus
aber merkmal grün um ein cut es ist grün
es ist grün und mein gott wird mal wie
sieht mein gott okay wenn mir einer
erzählen kann das aus minecraft so ich
hab das schon ein punkt markiert da
hinten habe ich schon den punkt im
wasser markiert er ist genau jetzt ist
sie ihr seht das wasser steht darunter
steht in klammern 28 das ein meter ein
blog ist ein meter das heißt desto näher
ich angehe das turnier bin ich daran das
kann ich euch zb bei mir beim home sweet
home zeigen zum beispiel hier guckt mal
die metapher vom bass meter 08 so und
jetzt stehe ich so direkt darauf dass es
bin
nichts davon entfernt das jetzt hier
sehen egal ich glaube ihr versteht was
ich meine so jedenfalls die minimap ist
halt da oben eingeblendet dort sich die
außerdem mit plus 1 163 wenn ich mal auf
drei druck ist das dx koordinate und das
plus 104 ist ez koordinaten dass
darunter dieser 68 seiner die höhe sehr
wenig herum springen dann ist hier ein
bisschen an das sage ich mal also das
ist die y koordinaten da steht auch
hinter menu
also drücken einfach mal was also hier
können wir die enabled disable dass es
ein englischer können die an oder
ausmachen ränder tabs surfen oder cave
gibt es surface ist ganz normal mit
bäumen und so weiter da sieht man auf
diese ein bisschen das haus wenn er
dieser grüne punkt nicht mehr
die home ist ganz einfach hier sehen wir
gelb ist besand grün sind bäume das ist
jetzt zum beispiel die einfach mal
schnell wie wir es da hinten schon sehen
und da kommt so ein kleiner see wasser
keine ahnung
und dann gibt es noch cave da sehen wir
zum beispiel hier wo wir sind weniger
höhlen da sind dafür umso mehr hören
also genau in diesem bereich sind
ziemlich viele höhlen wartet man hier
könnte ziemlich deutlich eine höhle
auftreten zeigt der an weil hier
erhalten der relativ großes biomasse von
ganz unten nach ganz oben das heißt er
kann schon bei sehr guten höhle
auftreten
übrigens wollte ich euch kurz den zieht
eingeben also wenn ihr jetzt sehen wollt
dann schaut euch einfach an weil ich bin
nämlich genau da gespart und das ist
ziemlich geil da hat man sonst
und hier sind wirklich ist ich finde die
welt ziemlich cool also wenn ihr den
zieht haben wollte es war ein bisschen
wie die leute fragen da ist also einfach
mal abschalten dann so gut wartet mal
drücken wieder im und machen das ganz
toll wenn ich am besten des point kann
man an oder ausmachen also guckt man
hier oben auf der karte darf das blaue
kreuz den kann ich hier war also der ist
immer noch da aber also den kann man
miteinander ausmachen aber wenn ich
sterbe wird er dann angezeigt oder nicht
ich bin vorhin schon habe ich bin ich
hoch geflogen hat mich ins bett gemacht
will runtergefallen bleiben will ich
hier gestorben das heißt dann bin ich
wieder hier gesponnen und hab dann auf
der karte gesehen oder aber mein des
point an konnte ich ganz schnell dahin
laufen das ganz gut wenn man in einer
höhle ist dann wird er angezeigt weil er
auch auf genau der höhe angezeigt wird
also wenn ich in der höhle und gestärkt
gestorben wäre der punkt da unten
und naja es ist eigentlich ganz cool so
also das will ich auf jeden fall immer
an lassen
so drücken wir mal wieder m dann gibt es
ja noch ein paar mehr ob johnson war
minimap options also zb im moment wartet
das blöde das muss wieder aufzustellen
so zb show when you da seht ihr jetzt
rechts da wird er jetzt nicht angezeigt
also ich finde das ist eigentlich
relativ unnötig dann gibt es noch ein
paar andere sachen dass zum beispiel die
märkischen kreis ist wo man den norden
südwesten osten sieht oder all square
ich finde square am besten texte es dann
auch egal also 20 ms mehr so ein
bisschen fange textur her ein bisschen
anders wie eine map & sons mini mini map
ist er dann ja vier hektar oben drin
ich finde es minimap angeblichen
eigentlich ein bisschen schöner man kann
auch aus
ob die unten rechts oben rechts oben
links oder unten links sein soll
also hier sind wirklich so ein paar
verschiedene sachen oder zum beispiel
dass die schrift hat irgendwie andere
eine andere größe hat daher finde ich
eigentlich grace kelly immer ganz gut
dass man dass die sich quasi an passt
also das sind halt noch ganz viele
einstellungen die ihr hier einfach mal
treffen könnte die muss ich jetzt nicht
alle zeigen sollen das einzige was ich
euch noch zeigen weil dies ein paar
sachen wie zum beispiel kann man mit vor
umgehen und so weiter
hier kann man noch updates checken auto
update blabla das wichtigste ist
eigentlich noch waypoint und zwar schon
ein paar wakeboards gesetzt wir gesehen
ob da wasser dass mein home sweet home
dass der des point und ich habe hier
noch einen punkt gesetzt und zwar da
unten ist eine schlucht mich einfach
runter gesprungen appian way point
gesetzt wenn euch jetzt denkt was er
denn jetzt hin fliegen
ok ich jetzt mal auf die suche nach ein
bisschen schweinen no ich kann das
schweine gar nicht töten also blödes
beispiel jetzt ich kann es ja nicht
töten weil ich kein schwert dabei habe
das heißt ich setze mich einfach mal ein
waypoint drückt er einfach m blickt auf
waypoint dann habt ihr bisher und eure
jetzigen waypoint kann ich jetzt zum
beispiel wenn ihr da unten auf das grüne
topteams wie tauben oft machen dann ist
es weg also wieder da und das können wir
natürlich auch wenn wir drauf klicken
also hier einfach moment also moment
also hör ich das dem nutzer auswählt
hallo
genauso könnte hier auch ein paar sachen
verändern wie zum beispiel die farbe
oder irgendwie sowas und na ja also wir
können jetzt einfach mal auf add klicken
dann ist nämlich genau hier wo wir
stehen also wer diesen koordinaten ist
dann ein neuer waypoint dann können wir
einfach eingeben
video von debatte was aber gesagt jetzt
ein schwein schwein töten
ja so dr okay gut stand habe ich die
farbe ein stell ich mache das einfach
mal komplett weiß also wird man kann das
hier halt so umschreibt das ist eine
schöne farbe pink pink ist doch schön
freuen uns auch alle so klicken auf beck
blicken wir auf exit mio und dann sind
wir dann wissen wir hier rotwein töten
noch das wollte ich auch noch machen
dann gehen wir hin
oder ist ein schwein blablabla dann
tötet man erscheinen und das schwein
will einfach nicht sterben und wir
stellen dabei die komplette landschaft
was zu essen so schöner ist ja auch egal
er jedenfalls kann man sich sowas
schweinfurt möglich würden naja egal
das wollten
das wollte ich nämlich eigentlich zeigen
und zwar was man auch machen kann wenn
man es drückt hier konkret kann man hier
die ganzen kreis um stellen also für den
jetzt aufrufen in china zum beispiel als
er kann könnte das mit allen aufrufen
und na ja das wollte ich einfach mal
zeigen viele von euch kennen diesen mord
wahrscheinlich schon
ich kenne ihn auch schon etwas länger
und weiß halt nicht ob ich den jetzigen
nutzen soll oder nicht weil es halt
schon ein bisschen schiiten ist wenn man
weiß aber guck mal da wenig gestorben
das hat schon ein wenig blöd und na ja
ich würde auf jeden fall sagen mit
diesem blick auf das volle haus sehen
wir uns beim nächsten video ich würde
mich freuen wenn ihr einen daumen hoch
gibt wenn es euch gefallen hat und dann
würde ich sagen sehen uns beim jetzt mal
tschüss